director robert eggers latest film the
northman is being described as the most
accurate depiction of viking culture
ever rendered on film
it's very layered it's very deep even
the things out of focus in the back of
the shop they're all things that have
been carefully worked on archaeologist
neil price was one of three historical
advisors on the film he specialized in
viking objects buildings and religion
for a viking specialist it was very
special to see this world that i've been
researching for for decades come to life
in a form that you can pick up and hold
it was absolutely extraordinary
let's examine each weapon in the
northmen with the help of the film's
consultant
one of the key scenes a raid on a slavic
village a fortified settlement
someone is throwing a spear amleth grabs
it in midair and throws it straight back
that's actually an episode from the
icelandic sagas this amazing body of
medieval literature written down
centuries after the viking age in many
ways throughout the film robert has very
carefully drawn on that deep vein of
storytelling that goes all the way back
to the time of the vikings
the spears are made with very straight
shafts usually of ash wood the spear
point is a metal usually iron obviously
with a sharp point some of them for
throwing some of them for use in more
close combat they're also quite cheap
this is the basic weapon of the viking
edge everybody had a spear
the bow and arrow is also a
quintessential viking weapon and there
are so many different kinds of arrows
special ones to go through armor others
to cause enormous bloody flesh wounds
this is really a very important viking
weapon
another one of the main viking weapons
is the axe lots of different kinds short
axes for close combat you can throw them
amlith makes innovative use of them here
using it to climb a wall they have
wooden shafts the axe head itself is
made of iron very heavy absolutely
devastating in close combat the primary
defensive weapon is the shield they're
made of wood often of lime wood quite
thin but flexible and strong with a
frame around the outside often covered
in leather and in the center
is this round iron boss and what that is
actually is the handle on the back side
of the shield if your shield has been
hacked away in combat and all you're
left with is that iron boss on your fist
you can use it to punch people with so
the shield in some circumstances is an
offensive weapon as well it's absolutely
crucial to how the vikings fought apart
from the axe there are two main kinds of
bladed weapons there's the classic
viking sword either a single or a
double-edged weapon used for slashing
but there's also a smaller slimmer kind
of blade which is what you see amlath
using in the raid on the village they're
usually known as fighting knives or
battle knives and these can be used to
stab to slash to hack or to cut they're
nasty things you can see that amleth has
the the scabbard for this sword
horizontally at his waist and that seems
to be how they were worn at least to
judge from how we find them in burials
the swords are made of iron very very
carefully made sometimes with edges of
steel they can be made with patterns in
the blade in the film is a special sword
and it's a sword with a name and this
idea of a named weapon is something that
we find very often in the icelandic
sagas a really illustrious warrior would
have a sword with a name and a history
these are swords that are inherited or
given as gifts or taken from fallen
enemies and everybody knew the story of
these weapons what you see here is
silver arm rings with animal heads on
the terminals and the arm ring is a very
common item of jewelry in the viking age
mainly for men it seems to have been
some kind of symbol of loyalty there are
images on carved stones of men waving
rings in the air and that's perhaps what
these ones mean on amla's arms here
most of the film is taking place in the
early 10th century the 1920s 930s the
time that we call the viking age is from
about 7 50 to around 10 50. at the time
of the movie the scandinavians have
traveled over an enormous
part of the world the early 10th century
when this is going on the scandinavians
are really well established on these
rivers connecting the baltic and the
black sea all of scandinavia is
essentially a maritime culture there's
few places that are really far from the
sea it's the rivers that are kind of
watery motorways that take those ships
deep into the heart of the mainland to
attack towns and villages and then to
get back up those rivers out to the open
sea before anyone can stop them
the boat that we see them rowing is a
classic viking longship rather a small
model actually the biggest could hold
120 men their shallow draft easy to get
into the rivers so this is the machine
that made the viking age possible
a lot of the settlements along the
eastern rivers were defended in some way
either with a bank of earth or a
palisade a wall of some kind director
robert eggers wanted to avoid
romanticizing the northmen instead the
film portrays vikings warts and all
viking raids were very very violent it's
important to see what this kind of
raiding really was how bad it was this
kind of scene the attack on more or less
defenseless settlements looking for loot
looking for plunder looking for slaves
this plays out all over western europe
and all over the east these vikings do
appalling things
and they're shown to be appalling this
is a raid as it really was
one of the most important things to
grasp about viking age scandinavia is
that this is a slave economy enslaved
people human beings
form an absolutely
fundamental foundation to how viking age
society runs it's a nightmare kidnapping
people trafficking them taking them back
and using them as forced labor and worse
i'm particularly
happy that the film has managed to
convey
is just how ubiquitous this was and the
enslaved are present all the way through
this film and that's an important thing
to understand about the vikings i think
it's been missing from our picture of
them for far too long in some scenes
that they're shackled with iron chains
and links these are direct copies of
examples that come from archaeological
excavations the film's attention to
detail carries over into the depiction
of the rich inner and spiritual life of
vikings something that recurs throughout
the film is a special kind of ritual and
magic something resembling shamanism
actually a fake is said and you cannot
escape it i'm really happy with how it's
depicted in the film this was a central
part of the way in which viking age
people got in touch with the other world
and it's also clear that this was an
arena above all of women's power
women were the gatekeepers of the world
of sorcery the world of magic this is a
world that is absolutely teeming with
spiritual life a kind of invisible
population i have the cunning to break
their minds
one of the things that that in some ways
sets apart the people of the viking age
at this time is that unlike most of
their neighbors they are not christians
they are still part of this very deep
ancient set of beliefs that goes back
way earlier than the vikings something
that has really sort of set the internet
alight from the trailer is the image of
a valkyrie the word valkyrie valkyria in
in old norse means chooser of the slain
their job is to find the best warriors
and to take them into the afterlife to
serve in odin and freyja's armies for
the battle at the end of the world the
ragnarok i think often they tend to now
be rather sort of stereotyped and
especially sexualized and it's something
that robert was very keen to avoid and
the valkyries as we see them here are
exactly as they should be they are
warlike they're violent and they are
terrifying
with the viking age you're going back a
thousand years there's a lot we don't
know so it's not possible for any
historical advisor to give the
filmmakers the same level of detail our
image of the viking age is the end
result of hundreds and hundreds of years
of gradual distortion that started
pretty much in the viking age itself and
has continued ever since and what i hope
is that at least to some degree this
movie will will kind of peel away all
those centuries of distortion and show
us
perhaps a little bit of a glimpse of
what the viking edge was really like
[Music]